monde
bonjour à tous c'est paléo news
l'émission qui fait des news avec du
vieux au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui des moustaches un dinosaure
géant de l'adn des patates douces et
plus encore puisque j'ai une bonne
raison de parler de mes propres
recherches
on commence par une étude de votre
humble serviteur qui vient de suggérer
que les moustaches et les poils des
mammifères pourrait être un paru chez
les thérapies site prémat mallya il y a
de cela entre 240 et 245 millions
d'années au début du trias avec mes
collègues sud africain nous avons montré
que l'évolution des moustaches qui en
temps normal ne fossilise pas peut être
indirectement reconstruite grâce à
l'évolution du canal osseux dunaire qui
les énerve et qu'il lui faut si lisse
très bien nous avons ainsi pu montrer
qu'à l'instar des mammifères dont ils
sont les ancêtres
certains terap site prémat magna
possédait déjà des moustaches certaines
de ces espèces et en nocturne les
moustaches les aurait aidés à s'orienter
dans le noir à l'abri des archosaures
devenu dominant nous y soulignons aussi
la possibilité que ces moustaches la
fourrure mais aussi l'apparition des
glandes mammaires soit tout contrôlé par
un seul et même gène qui serait en
quelque sorte le gène faisant de nous
des mammifères et puisqu'on parle d'art
causeur dominant voici l'empreinte de
padt a théropodes géant un dinosaure
carnivore qui a été découvert en bolivie
cette empreinte tridactyles datant du
crétacé a toutes les chances d'avoir
appartenu à un prédateur de grande
taille comme un giganotosaurus car les
dinosaures herbivores de cette région à
cette époque est susceptible de produire
de tels empreintes étaient tous trop
petits on reste dans les empreintes avec
ses magnifiques traces de pieds
attribuées à homo erectus et qui ont été
retrouvées au kenya elle date de 1,5
million d'années et montre que nos
ancêtres marché bel et bien debout et
vivait en groupe
rien de nouveau sous le soleil diront
certains mais dois-je vous rappeler que
contrairement aux ossements les
empreintes de pas sont des faux cils qui
ont été faites par des animaux de leur
vivant alors oui on s'en doutait déjà
mais maintenant on a la preuve en chair
et en roche et ça c'est plutôt classe
toujours chez nos ancêtres les
paléontologues rapporte la découverte de
tumeurs osseuses fossilisés chez des
australopithèques d'afrique du sud cette
humeur sont les plus anciennes preuves
de cancer dans la lignée humaine
puisqu'elle date de plus de deux
millions d'années découvertes sur un os
de pied et une vertèbre
elle montre que le régime paléo n'a pas
toujours réussi à nos ancêtres
enfin les analyses génétiques sur les
populations des îles adam en eau révélé
que leurs ancêtres se sont hybridés avec
une autre population humaine ayant
diverger de la nôtre il y à au moins 300
mille ans on savait déjà que des
populaires
sumène moderne c'est est hybride et avec
des hommes de néanderthal et des
denisova mais cette fois ci il ne
s'agirait ni de l'un ni de l'autre
on ne sait pas encore qui est cet
hominidé mystère peut-être s'agit-il
d'une nouvelle espèce comme le suggèrent
les auteurs de l'étude
mais étant donné les dates avancées et
la localisation géographique on espère
secrètement que ces jeunes puissent
provenir du tout récemment disparu homme
de flores la curiosité de l'émission
c'est la découverte de deux petites
ailes magnifiquement préservé dans
delambre de birmanie est âgé de près de
100 millions d'années n'est plus miss
ont préservé avec une exquise finesse la
petite taille et les doigts griffus très
nettement visibles après le passage aux
rayons x indique qu'il s'agissait
certainement de très jeunes oiseaux et
nature need dans la rubrique vintage
aujourd'hui je vous propose de revenir
en 2012
caroline roulier alors en thèse à
montpellier avait démontré en étudiant
leurs gènes que les patates douces de
polynésie venait en fait d'amérique du
sud et il y avait été introduite il y a
dix mille ans de cela environ
cela signifie que des milliers d'années
avant christophe colomb ou même les
vikings les polynésiens ces intrépides
navigateur aurait traversé le pacifique
jusque sur la côte ouest de l'amérique
du sud pour en ramener le précieux
tubercule
cette hypothèse est renforcée par le
fait que les polynésiens appelle la
patate douce de sont donc échoué à la
kumara si on vous avait dit que
l'histoire de votre espèce donnée dans
le génome d'une patate vous ne l'auriez
sûrement jamais cru le coup de coeur
coups de gueule de cette émission c'est
évidemment la folie pokémon go de l'été
qui suscite à la fois enthousiasme et
des bas enthousiasme de la part du musée
d'ottawa au canada qui voit
l'opportunité de se faire un peu de pub
avec cette très jolie photo enthousiasme
aussi de la part des auteurs du site
mother board qui y voient un moyen de
sensibiliser la population et notamment
les plus jeunes à la biodiversité et à
la taxonomie c'est à dire la science de
la classification des espèces
vous n'êtes certainement pas sans savoir
qu'en cherchant des animaux virtuels
vous pouvez en rencontrer de véritables
et la revue nature s'interroge justement
sur les bénéfices à tirer de ces
rencontres fortuites la revue souligne
notamment des précédents comme cette
personne qui a découvert une nouvelle
espèce de sauterelle sur une photo de
profil facebook
elle rappelle néanmoins qu on ne décrit
pas de nouvelles espèces uniquement à
partir de photos etc un spécimen de
chair et de sang ou de celle ci c'est
une plante doit impérativement être
conservés dans une institution publique
d'autres se montrent par contre plus
sceptiques en effet déjà à l'époque des
tout premiers jeux pokémon des
chercheurs avaient souligné les
exceptionnelle aptitude des enfants à
apprendre de nombreux noms d'espèces et
comment ses aptitudes été gaspillés dans
la connaissance de la peau qui taxonomie
à l'article de conversations africa
rappelle les chiffres selon lesquels les
enfants ne reconnaissait à l'époque que
58 % des espèces du monde réel contre
78% des pokémon il pose aussi la
question de l'intérêt que les joueurs de
pokémon go porte à la nature qui les
entoure une fois que la batterie de leur
téléphone est à plat et vous qu'est ce
que vous faites est ce que vous profitez
du paysage ou bien est ce que vous vous
dépêcher d'aller recharger votre
téléphone
un bon moyen de réconcilier tout le
monde serait d'inventer une application
qui transformerait votre smartphone en
véritable pokédex à espèces réel pour en
savoir plus tous les liens sont dans la
description c'était paléo news merci de
l'avoir suivi abonnez vous pour ne rien
manquer d'anciens à très bientôt